Pourquoi est-ce qu’on dort?
Hé, c’est important comme question,
on passe tout de même presque
1/3 de notre existence au lit.
Mais pourquoi?
Pourquoi est-ce qu’on a BESOIN de dormir?
Eh bien aussi incroyable que cela paraisse,
on n’en sait rien.
Alors oui, vous allez me dire, on a besoin de
dormir parce que sinon on est fatigué.
Ok, mais en fait la fatigue, c’est juste un
signal que nous envoie notre organisme
pour nous indiquer qu’il est temps de dormir.
Ce n’est pas la vraie raison profonde.
C’est comme si on disait: on mange
parce qu’on a faim.
Non, la sensation de faim c’est juste
un signal.
La raison profonde pour laquelle on mange,
c’est que notre organisme a besoin
de nutriments:
les glucides pour l’énergie, les protéines
comme briques élémentaires, etc.
Nous apporter ces nutriments, c’est la
fonction biologique de l’alimentation.
Et donc de la même façon, on peut se demander
quelle est la fonction biologique du sommeil.
A quoi il sert fondamentalement, qu’est-ce
qu’il apporte à notre organisme.
Et on n’en sait rien!
Il existe plusieurs hypothèses assez
convaincantes,
et je vais vous les expliquer, mais je vous
spoile la fin de la vidéo:
aussi étonnant que ça paraisse,
il n’existe pas de consensus ferme
chez les scientifiques sur cette question.
On ne sait pas vraiment pourquoi on dort.
[jingle]
Une manière simple, en apparence,
pour essayer de découvrir
la fonction biologique du sommeil,
c’est de regarder ce qu’il se
passe si on arrête de dormir.
Les impacts physiologiques de la privation.
Chez l’être humain, on n’a pas grand
chose de scientifique sur le sujet.
Le record « officiel » de temps passé
sans dormir
aurait été établi par un américain,
Randy Gardner, en 1964.
C’est du moins le cas le mieux documenté
scientifiquement.
Sous l’œil de médecins, et
de chercheurs spécialisés,
Gardner aurait passé 11 jours sans
dormir du tout.
Et contrairement à ce qu’on pourrait penser,
il n’en est pas mort,
ou n’est pas devenu fou.
Évidemment, à la fin, il avait quelques
problèmes d’humeur, de concentration,
de mémoire, et même apparemment quelques
hallucinations occasionnelles.
Mais rien de grave, pas de dégâts apparents
à son organisme,
et il s’en est remis complètement
en quelques jours.
Supposément, son record aurait été
battu plusieurs fois par la suite,
il y a plusieurs histoires comme ça,
mais pour des raisons de sécurité,
le Guiness des records n’homologue plus
les nouvelles tentatives.
Quoiqu’il en soit, chez l’être humain,
personne n’est jamais officiellement mort
de la seule « privation de sommeil ».
Chez les animaux, il existe plusieurs études
scientifiques un peu moins anecdotiques,
et assez cruelles, on ne va pas se mentir.
Les premières ont eu lieu avec des chiens,
à la fin du XIXe siècle.
Le protocole était simple, dès qu’ils
semblaient s’endormir,
on les réveillait et on les forçait
à marcher.
Eh bien ils sont tous morts en deux semaines,
et les autopsies ont révélé de nombreuses
lésions, notamment au cerveau.
Il y a eu par la suite d’autres études du
le même genre,
mais toutes ont un problème méthodologique:
comment être sûr que c’est bien le manque
de sommeil qui a tué les animaux,
et pas le stress associé au fait
de se faire réveiller périodiquement
par des méthodes pas hyper douces?
Et il a fallu attendre 1983 pour
que le biologiste
Allan Rechtschaffen propose un protocole
expérimental
permettant de s’affranchir
de ce biais.
L’idée était la suivante: On prend deux rats
que l’on place dans une cage divisée en deux.
Je vous mets une vue de face
et une vue de dessus.
On va appeler ces deux rats respectivement
le « sujet », et le « contrôle ».
Vous allez comprendre pourquoi.
On met de l’eau dans le fond de la cage
et on les place en hauteur sur une plateforme
qui est en fait un disque.
Ils ont accès à de la nourriture,
pas de problème de ce côté là.
Mais le rat « sujet », a en permanence
sur le crâne des électrodes
pour lui faire un électro-encéphalogramme.
Et grâce à ça, quand on détecte
qu’il va s’endormir,
on fait lentement tourner le disque sur
lequel ils se trouvent tous les deux.
Le mouvement du disque va les forcer
à se déplacer,
sous peine de tomber dans l’eau, ce
qu’il n’aiment pas particulièrement.
Le point clé avec ce dispositif, c’est
que la rotation n’est déclenchée
que quand c’est le rat « sujet »
qui s’apprête à s’endormir.
Et donc le rat contrôle lui peut arriver
à pioncer
de temps en temps quand l’autre
est réveillé.
L’idée de ce dispositif, c’est que le sujet
ne puisse pas dormir,
mais que les deux rats reçoivent la même
quantité de stress,
puisque le mouvement du disque est commun.
On peut donc a priori séparer l’effet du
stress de celui de la privation de sommeil.
Avec ce dispositif, les rats « sujets »
ont été en moyenne privés
de 90% de leur sommeil habituel,
alors que ça a été seulement 30 à 40%
de privation pour les rats « contrôles ».
Alors comment ça s’est fini?
Eh bien tous les rats « contrôle » ont
survécu sans problème,
mais tous les « sujets » sont morts
en 10 à 15 jours.
C’est à dire plus vite que si on les avait
privés de nourriture.
D’ailleurs ils ont perdu du poids, alors
qu’ils mangeaient environ 50% en plus.
L’autopsie a révélé des lésions sur la
peau, des œdèmes,
et un certain nombre d’atteintes
des organes:
chez certains c’était l’estomac,
chez d’autres les poumons,
la trachée, ou encore la vessie.
Mais aucun dommage qui soit commun,
identique chez tous les rats.
Le biologiste Allan Rechtschaffen n’a pas
été en mesure
de déterminer UNE cause anatomique unique
qui pourrait expliquer la mort des rats
privés de sommeil.
On ne comprend pas vraiment pourquoi
ils sont morts.
Donc on n’est pas beaucoup plus avancé,
pour essayer de comprendre à quoi sert
vraiment le sommeil.
En plus, un des problèmes de l’expérience
de Rechtschaffen, outre sa cruauté évidente,
c’est qu’elle n’a pas toujours donné la
même chose chez d’autres espèces.
On n’a pas pu reproduire le résultat ni chez
la souris, ni chez le pigeon par exemple.
Et à nouveau comme je vous le disais,
chez l’être humain,
on n’a aucun cas documenté fiable
de « mort par manque de sommeil ».
Derrière ces expériences, il y a l’idée
qu’étudier le sommeil chez les animaux
peut nous apprendre quelque chose sur le
sommeil pour l’être humain.
Mais est-ce que c’est vraiment le cas?
D’ailleurs: est-ce que tous les animaux
dorment?
Pour essayer de répondre à cette question,
il faut déjà s’entendre
sur ce qu’on appelle « le sommeil ».
Une définition classique, c’est de dire que
c’est un état d’immobilité,
accompagné d’une perte de conscience, d’une
réponse réduite aux stimulations externes.
Mais c’est un état qui est rapidement
réversible.
L’idée c’est de distinguer le sommeil
d’autres états physiologiques
comme le coma ou l’hibernation, qui eux
ne sont pas rapidement réversibles,
ça prend du temps d’en sortir.
Pour essayer de cerner un peu quelles sont
les espèces qui dorment,
regardons déjà parmi les vertébrés.
Chez les mammifères, a priori, oui,
tout le monde dort.
Parmi les plus de 6000 espèces que compte
cette classe,
on n’a jamais trouvé de contre-exemple.
Même si les études scientifiques
les plus poussées
n’ont été faites que pour quelques dizaines
d’espèces, la plupart domestiquées.
Chez les oiseaux, il semblerait aussi
que ce soit le cas,
même si on a plus de mal à l’étudier,
notamment dans le cas des oiseaux migrateurs.
Et avec eux, il peut y avoir
des particularités.
Une des espèces qui a été étudiée
c’est le bruant à couronne blanche,
un oiseau migrateur d’Amérique du Nord
qui se balade
suivant la saison, entre l’Alaska
et le Mexique.
Et visiblement, il est capable de réduire
sa durée de sommeil
de 85% en période de migration, sans
avoir besoin de récupérer ensuite.
Chez la frégate du pacifique,
c’est encore plus étonnant.
En 2016, des chercheurs ont réussi à poser
des électro-encéphalogrammes miniatures
à une quinzaine de ces oiseaux,
et ont montré qu’elles pouvaient voler
10 jours en continu sans se poser.
Elles arrivaient à grappiller environ
40 minutes de sommeil chaque nuit,
tout en restant en l’air en profitant
de courants ascendants.
Chez les reptiles et les amphibiens,
il semblerait qu’il y ait un état
qu’on puisse considérer comme du sommeil,
même si chez certaines espèces,
on a du mal à le démontrer avec certitude.
Il existe parfois des études qui
se contredisent l’une l’autre.
Chez les poissons, il existe aussi
manifestement un état
qu’on peut considérer comme étant comparable
au sommeil,
même s’il est difficile de prouver
qu’il a bien les mêmes caractéristiques
que pour les mammifères par exemple.
D’ailleurs un cas particulièrement
intéressant, est celui des mammifères marins.
Quand elle se trouve sur terre, l’otarie
aurait un sommeil
comparable à celui des autres mammifères.
Mais dans l’eau, elle semble capable
de faire dormir
les deux moitiés de son cerveau
indépendamment, une par une.
C’est ce qu’on appelle techniquement le
sommeil uni-hémisphérique.
On retrouve la même chose chez le dauphin.
Quand il dort, il ne met en sommeil
que la moitié de son cerveau.
Il fait ça en continuant à nager et change
de moitié toutes les deux heures environ.
Autre spécificité qu’on retrouve chez
les dauphins et les orques:
pendant les 6 à 8 semaines qui suivent
la naissance,
ni la mère ni le nouveau-né ne dorment.
Du tout. Pendant 2 mois.
Et ensuite ils se remettent à dormir,
mais sans avoir besoin de rattraper,
il n’y a pas de dette de sommeil.
Incroyable, non?
Voilà, ça c’était pour les vertébrés.
En ce qui concerne les autres espèces,
ça devient vraiment difficile de savoir.
Chez les insectes, on retrouve parfois
un état qui s’apparente à du sommeil,
mais visiblement pas systématiquement.
En conclusion, le sommeil est quelque chose
de très répandu,
probablement universel au moins
chez les vertébrés.
Mais on voit que ses caractéristiques
peuvent être très différentes
d’une espèce à l’autre,
même pour des espèces qui semblent proches
dans l’arbre du vivant.
Tout ça suggère que le sommeil remplit
certainement une fonction vraiment vitale.
Il faut voir que quand un animal dort, il
est plus vulnérable aux prédateurs.
Et en plus c’est du temps qu’il ne passe pas
à faire des choses comme se nourrir,
ou se reproduire.
Donc si le sommeil a été conservé par
l’évolution malgré ses inconvénients,
c’est qu’il doit être sacrément utile.
Par contre le fait que les caractéristiques
du sommeil soient
si variable d’une espèce à l’autre
peut laisser penser
qu’il a pu apparaitre initialement
pour une certaine fonction, mais en acquérir
d’autres avec le temps.
Une caractéristique intéressante à
comparer chez les différentes espèces,
c’est la durée du sommeil, car elle varie
de seulement quelques heures,
à presque toute la journée.
Et chez les mammifères, elle semble
très liée à la taille de l’animal.
Sur ce graphique, vous voyez différents
mammifères
avec leur masse corporelle
et leur temps de sommeil moyen.
Pour la masse, c’est en échelle
logarithmique.
Et vous voyez qu’on va de 3h environ
pour l’éléphant,
jusqu’à plus de 12h pour des petits rongeurs.
Et ça dépend aussi du régime alimentaire, sur
ce graphique vous n’avez que des herbivores.
Mais pour certains carnivores on a des
temps de sommeil encore plus élevés,
jusqu’à 20h pour certaines
espèces de chauves-souris.
Le fait que la durée de sommeil dépende
à la fois du régime alimentaire
et de la masse corporelle suggère fortement
que le sommeil puisse avoir un rôle
dans le métabolisme.
On sait que les petits animaux ont un taux
métabolique plus élevé.
Le taux métabolique c’est la quantité
d’énergie consommée chaque jour,
divisée par la masse de l’animal.
Et les petits animaux consomment
plus d’énergie par kilo,
ce qui semble lié à leur temps de sommeil.
Une première hypothèse simple sur le
rôle métabolique du sommeil,
c’est de dire qu’il sert simplement
à économiser de l’énergie.
C’est d’ailleurs le sens intuitif
de « se reposer ».
Et pourtant cette explication n’est pas
totalement satisfaisante.
En effet pour accomplir cet objectif,
économiser de l’énergie,
on pourrait se contenter d’un état calme,
mais dans lequel on reste éveillé.
Quand vous êtes avachis dans votre canapé,
vous ne consommez pas plus d’énergie
qu’en dormant.
Donc si c’était simplement une question
d’économie d’énergie, pourquoi dormir?
Pourquoi se mettre dans un état
où on perd conscience?
Ce qui est quand même assez dangereux,
notamment vis-à-vis des prédateurs.
Le fait que l’on perde conscience
quand on dort laisse penser
que le sommeil a quelque chose à voir
spécifiquement avec le cerveau,
pas juste de l’économie d’énergie
en général.
Or justement le métabolisme dans le cerveau,
c’est quelque chose d’assez particulier.
Déjà il faut savoir que si votre cerveau
ne représente
que 2% de votre masse corporelle, il consomme
20% de votre énergie.
Son taux métabolique est donc 10 fois
supérieur à la moyenne de votre corps.
Une sacré machine!
Or le problème du métabolisme en général,
c’est qu’il a comme des effets
secondaires indésirables.
Un des plus notable, c’est la production
de ce qu’on appelle des radicaux libres.
Il s’agit d’espèces chimiques qui sont
produites lors des processus de respiration,
ou certains mécanismes immunitaires, et qui
contiennent un atome d’oxygène très réactif,
et donc susceptible d’aller
abîmer d’autres molécules,
comme les protéines, l’ADN ou encore
les lipides de la membrane cellulaire.
Ces radicaux libres sont donc un
peu comme des déchets toxiques,
qui sont heureusement neutralisés par des
molécules qu’on appelle les anti-oxydants,
c’est le cas de certaines vitamines qu’on
trouve entre autres dans les fruits et légumes.
En plus de cela, notre organisme possède
des mécanismes de défense spécifiques
contre les radicaux libre.
D’une part il fabrique des enzymes
antioxydantes,
et d’autre part il y a un traitement assez
radical:
si une cellule devient trop endommagée,
elle est tout simplement détruite
et remplacée.
Sauf que ça, c’est compliqué dans le
cerveau.
Comme vous le savez sans doute,
la plupart des cellules cérébrales
ne peuvent pas se diviser,
et donc sauf exception, vos neurones
ne peuvent pas être renouvelés.
En résumé avec le cerveau, on a un organe
qui a un métabolisme 10 fois plus élevé
que la normale,
et dans lequel on ne peut pas se permettre
de perdre des cellules
du fait des dégâts causés
par les radicaux libre.
Et le sommeil, ce serait tout simplement
la réponse à cela.
Une période d’activité cérébrale
fortement réduite,
avec un métabolisme plus bas, et qui permette
de façon efficace la suppression
des radicaux libres.
Une étude de 2019 a même mis en
évidence que pendant le sommeil,
le liquide cérébro-spinal circulerait de
façon accrue,
ce qui semble aller dans le sens
de cette idée.
Le sommeil serait du « lavage de cerveau »,
au sens strict.
Voici en gros ce qui constitue la
théorie métabolique du sommeil,
qui expliquerait donc la nécessité de mettre
notre cerveau en veilleuse
chaque jour, ou chaque nuit.
Alors ça semble assez convaincant, mais
il y a un truc qui ne colle pas très bien.
On sait très bien que le sommeil, ça n’est
pas juste éteindre notre cerveau.
Au milieu de notre sommeil il peut y avoir
des phases pas du tout reposantes,
où notre cerveau fonctionne à fond:
les rêves, ce qu’on appelle le sommeil
paradoxal.
Qu’est-ce qu’il fait là, lui?
[jingle]
Pour comprendre et analyser les différentes
phases du sommeil,
on utilise généralement un
électroencéphalogramme, un EEG,
qui permet de constater que le sommeil
se déroule en cycles.
Au cours d’un cycle, on passe progressivement
de l’éveil à une phase de sommeil léger
puis profond, et on termine par une phase
très étonnante,
dont le tracé en EEG est très différent
de celui du sommeil profond:
c’est le sommeil paradoxal.
Les cycles de sommeil durent environ 1h30
chez l’être humain,
et vous remarquez que leur composition
varie au cours de la nuit:
il y a de moins en moins de sommeil profond
et de plus en plus de sommeil paradoxal.
C’est cela probablement qui est à l’origine
de l’adage de grand-mère
qui dit que les heures de sommeil
avant minuit sont les plus reposantes,
et en contrepartie, qu’on rêve surtout en
fin de nuit, juste avant de se réveiller.
Outre les rêves, on sait que cette phase
de sommeil paradoxal s’accompagne
d’une très forte activité cérébrale,
notamment dans les aires motrices,
celles qui sont normalement
responsables de nos mouvements.
Mais ce qui est pratique, c’est qu’il y
a en même temps
la suppression de certains neurotransmetteurs,
pour éviter que l’on bouge vraiment:
notre cerveau croit qu’on bouge, mais
physiquement on ne bouge pas.
Notez qu’il y a une exception à ça,
ce sont les yeux,
les mouvements oculaires sont maintenus
pendant le sommeil paradoxal,
et c’est d’ailleurs ce qui donne son nom
à cette phase en anglais:
REM pour Rapid Eye Movement.
Pendant cette phase de sommeil paradoxal,
notre cerveau fonctionne
presque comme s’il était réveillé,
et consomme autant d’énergie,
ce qui semble invalider, au moins
partiellement,
la théorie métabolique de suppression
des radicaux libres.
Une autre fonction qui a donc été suggérée
et qui pourrait expliquer de façon générale
le rôle du sommeil,
c’est son impact sur la mémoire.
Je pense que vous savez tous que
le manque de sommeil a un impact
sur vos capacités cognitives en général,
et en particulier sur vos facultés
à apprendre et à mémoriser.
Il existe un certain nombre d’études
à ce sujet,
dont certaines qui montrent par exemple
qu’on oublie moins quand on apprend
juste avant une période de sommeil.
Donc révisez plutôt le soir.
Une hypothèse initiale qui avait été
envisagée dans cette veine,
c’est de dire que pour bien mémoriser,
notre cerveau a besoin
d’avoir régulièrement une période dénuée
de stimulus externe,
et donc sans aucune information nouvelle
à enregistrer.
Comme un disque dur qui aurait besoin
de refroidir.
A l’appui de cette hypothèse, des études
ont montré
que des rats avaient un excès de sommeil
paradoxal
après avoir appris à s’orienter
dans un labyrinthe.
L’effet pouvait durer plusieurs jours, et
augmenter avec la complexité du labyrinthe.
Tout ça est intéressant, mais on ne comprend
pas très bien pourquoi
spécifiquement du sommeil paradoxal.
Si l’idée est que le sommeil permet d’offrir
simplement au cerveau
une période sans information à mémoriser,
du sommeil profond ferait tout aussi bien
l’affaire.
Tout cela a conduit à une hypothèse
plus subtile:
le sommeil aurait un rôle actif
sur la mémoire.
Ce ne serait pas une période de repos
de la mémoire,
mais plutôt de consolidation de celle-ci.
Pour le comprendre, on peut regarder
un des modèles les plus simples
du fonctionnement de notre mémoire.
Dans ce modèle, la mémorisation
fait intervenir
une mémoire à court terme
et une mémoire à long terme,
reliées par deux processus:
l’encodage et la consolidation.
Lors de l’exposition à des stimulus,
l’encodage permet le stockage rapide
dans la mémoire à court terme,
une mémoire immédiate.
Puis un second processus, dit
de consolidation ou de stockage
assure son transfert dans
une mémoire à long-terme.
Ces deux mémoires pouvant se situer
dans des zones du cerveau différentes,
typiquement l’hippocampe et le néocortex.
L’hypothèse du rôle actif du sommeil sur
la mémoire propose
que ces deux processus utilisent les mêmes
neurones, mais pas de la même façon
et donc que l’encodage soit prioritaire
lors des phases d’éveil,
tandis que la consolidation serait facilitée
lors des phases de sommeil.
Cela peut se produire via différents
mécanismes.
D’une part, lors du sommeil, il serait
possible pour le cerveau
de supprimer les connexions inutiles,
c’est-à-dire en gros d’oublier
tout ce qui ne mérite pas d’être retenu.
Mais en plus de cela, le cerveau aurait la
capacité à réactiver les souvenirs encodés,
comme s’il les rejouait, de manière
à les ancrer, les consolider,
et éventuellement modifier leur
organisation et leur stockage.
Pour reprendre l’analogie du disque dur,
le sommeil ce serait cette phase où aucune
information nouvelle n’est inscrite,
et le disque en profite pour vider
la corbeille, compresser certaines informations,
déplacer des fichiers pour les réorganiser,
faire un back-up, etc.
Cette thèse est assez séduisante, et semble
étayée par des visualisations
en IRM ou en PET qui montrent
qu’effectivement
au cours des phases de sommeil, des zones
de mémoire se réactivent
et correspondent à celles activées au cours
des apprentissages qui ont précédé.
Alors très bien, mais il reste tout de même
une question:
pourquoi il y aurait à la fois du sommeil
paradoxal et du sommeil profond?
Eh bien il est possible que ces deux phases
de sommeil jouent un rôle
sur deux types de mémoire différents.
Pour le sommeil profond ce serait plutôt
la mémoire déclarative, ou explicite,
celle qui vous permet de mémoriser
et restituer des mots,
des phrases, des informations en général.
Et pour le sommeil paradoxal, il s’agirait
plutôt
de consolider la mémoire procédurale,
ou implicite,
c’est-à-dire celle qui permet la mémorisation
de certains gestes
comme de conduire un voiture, jouer au tennis
ou faire du piano.
Cette distinction collerait assez bien
avec l’idée
que le sommeil paradoxal correspond à
une réactivation
et une consolidation des apprentissages
moteurs.
Ce qui expliquerait que quand on rêve,
on se voit faire des gestes
et que les zones motrices correspondantes
soient activées.
Cette idée colle aussi d’ailleurs plutôt bien
avec la répartition
assez étonnante du sommeil paradoxal chez
les différentes espèces.
Chez l’humain, sa proportion est très élevée
chez le bébé, puis décroit avec l’âge.
A côté de ça, le dauphin n’en a
tout simplement pas,
zéro sommeil paradoxal, semble-t-il.
Tandis que le recordman serait
l’ornithorynque,
avec pas loin de 8 heures de sommeil
paradoxal chaque jour.
Et il aurait même la capacité de pratiquer
les deux formes de sommeil en même temps
dans des zones différentes de son cerveau.
Or ces différentes durées de sommeil
paradoxal semblent en cohérence
avec le degré de maturité des nouveaux-nés
de ces espèces.
Les humains et les ornithorynques naissent
en étant dépourvus
de tout un tas de fonctions motrices
qui seront nécessaires à leur survie.
Tandis que les dauphins naissent
en sachant déjà parfaitement nager,
et n’ont plus rien à apprendre
de ce côté-là.
Cette thèse du rêve comme consolidation des
apprentissages moteurs
rejoint assez bien une proposition plus
ancienne
du chercheur Michel Jouvet,
le neurobiologiste français
qui dans lesannées 50 avait découvert
le sommeil paradoxal.
Pour lui, le rêve était une sorte
de simulateur de vie,
un jeu en réalité virtuelle que se construit
notre cerveau pour s’entrainer
en toute sécurité à apprendre à réagir aux
différentes situations de la vraie vie.
En conclusion de tout ce qu’on a raconté
aujourd’hui,
vous voyez que deux grandes hypothèses
s’affrontent
quant à la fonction biologique qui
expliquerait la nécessité du sommeil.
Et il en existe aussi d’autres, comme
l’hypothèse qui postule
un rôle du sommeil sur notre système
immunitaire.
Mais retenez bien qu’à l’heure actuelle,
il n’y a pas de consensus scientifique
sur la question,
et les partisans des deux camps débattent
vivement
à coup de publications scientifiques.
Pour préparer cet épisode, je me suis donc
basé sur de nombreux articles
écrits par des gens pas toujours
d’accord entre eux.
A titre d’illustration, je me suis beaucoup
inspiré des articles de Jerome Siegel,
un chercheur de UCLA qui est un des plus
réputés dans le domaine,
et qui semble plutôt partisan
de la théorie métabolique.
Eh bien pas plus tard qu’il y a
quelques semaines,
il a écrit un article pour attaquer
la théorie de la mémoire,
en disant que la consolidation marche
aussi bien que l’on dorme ou pas,
et que ça ne peut donc pas expliquer
la fonction biologique du sommeil.
Il faut donc rester prudent et
ne pas conclure trop vite
dans un sens ou dans l’autre, d’autant
qu’il est possible
que tous ces chercheurs aient raison…
simultanément.
On peut imaginer que le sommeil soit apparu
il y a environ 600 millions d’années,
chez un ancêtre commun des insectes
et des vertébrés,
par exemple pour des raisons de métabolisme,
ce qui pourrait expliquer
qu’on le retrouve de façon presque
universelle chez toutes ces espèces
et peut-être a-t-il ensuite acquis d’autres
fonctions,
liées à la consolidation de la mémoire,
par exemple
qui expliqueraient l’existence
du sommeil paradoxal.
Dans tous les cas la recherche continue
sur ce grand mystère de la biologie,
et en attendant de savoir, n’oubliez
pas de dormir suffisamment,
au moins 7 heures par jour pour
les adultes, c’est important.
Voilà merci d’avoir suivi la vidéo.
N’oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaine
si ce contenu vous plait,
et de partager à vos amis qui ne dorment
pas assez.
Si vous voulez des précisions
et des compléments,
il y a comme toujours un billet de blog
qui accompagne la vidéo,
le lien est en description.
Et nous on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos, à bientôt!
– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'oreille -